So far, we have seen how to add and
subtract vectors, and
we have seen how to multiply
vectors by scalars.
This might lead you to ask,
can we multiply two vectors?
It turns out that there are several
different notions of vector
multiplication.
Perhaps the first one we might think of,
just multiplying corresponding
coordinates, doesn't turn out to
be useful in many applications.
However, there are other notions of
multiplication, which are very useful.
One of the most important operations
we can perform on vectors is
the inner product, also called the dot
product, since we often represent
it by placing a dot between
the vectors being multiplied.
It's important stems from its
geometric interpretation.
It let's us find the angle
between two different vectors.
More precisely,
the inner product of the vectors, v and
w, in Euclidean space,
satisfies the following identity,
v dot w equals the magnitude
of v times the magnitude of w,
times the cosine of theta, where theta
is the angle between the vectors, v and
w, if we were to draw them
emanating from the same point.
Technically, there are two angles
between the vectors, a shorter one and
a longer one.
We always use the shorter
one by convention.
Note that the inner product of two
vectors is a number, not a vector.
Using the inverse of
the cosine function,
also called the arc cosine function,
we can solve for this angle.
It equals the arc cosine of
the dot product of v and w,
divided by the product of
the magnitudes of v and w.
Another way we can think of this
formula is as the following.
The arc cosine of the normalization of
v dotted with the normalization of w.
Of course, unless we have a nicer way
of computing the dot product of two
vectors, this formula
doesn't do us much good.
It turns out that there is a nicer
way to compute the inner product,
and it is similar to our first candidate
notion for multiplying vectors.
To compute v dot w, we can multiply
the corresponding components of v and
w, and
then we can add those products together.
So, for example,
the dot product of the vectors 1,
2, -1 and 3, 1, 0 is 1 times 3,
plus 2 times 1, plus -1 times 0,
which equals 5.
This means that the angle between these
two vectors is the dot product of v and
w, which is 5,
divided by the magnitude of v, which is
the square root of 6, and the magnitude
of w, which is the square root of 10.
This gives about 0.87 radians,
which is about 50 degrees.
There are some interesting consequences
of this connection between the inner
product of two vectors and their angle.
First, recall that the cosine
of x is always bounded
below by -1 and above by 1,
no matter what x is.
Using the earlier equation,
that the dot product of v and
w is the product of the magnitudes
times cosine of theta,
we see that the dot product is bounded
below by negative magnitude of v
times magnitude of w, and above by
magnitude of v times magnitude of w.
We can express this inequality more
succinctly as the absolute value of v
dot w is less than or equal to the
product of the magnitudes of v and w.
This is a famous inequality called
the Cauchy-Schwarz Inequality,
and you will see this inequality
pop up all over linear algebra and
mathematics, in general.
Let's assume, for the moment,
that neither v nor w is the zero vector,
which would mean that their dot
product is automatically zero.
What does it mean if v dot w
actually equals the magnitude of v
times the magnitude of w?
From our earlier equation, it means
that the cosine of theta equals 1,
and this tells us that theta must equal
0 in both degrees and in radians.
In other words, the vectors, v and w,
are pointing in the same direction.
Similarly, if v dot w equals
the negative of the product
of the magnitudes, we can conclude
that cosine of theta equals -1,
which means that theta equals
pi radians, or 180 degrees.
And that, in turn, means that v and
w are pointing in opposite directions.
Finally, if v dot w equals 0, then,
since we assumed that neither v nor
w was the zero vector, this means
that cosine of theta must equal 0.
This means that theta equals pi
over 2 radians, or 90 degrees.
So, v and
w are at a right angle to each other.
One last thing to consider is what
happens when you take the dot product
of a vector with itself.
In this case, the angle between
the two vectors is 0, both radians and
degrees, so,
cosine of theta will equal 1.
So our formula reduces to v dot v
equals the magnitude of v squared.
After a little rearrangement,
we can see that the magnitude of v
equals the square root of v dot v.
This gives us another interpretation
of the magnitude of a vector,
this time in terms of its dot product.